for almost one year now Russia's war of
aggression has been sowing death and
destruction
Putin is not only waging a brutal war on
the battlefield
but he is also viciously targeting
civilians
and the aggressor has to pay for this
today we're turning up the pressure with
a tenth package of sanctions
first we propose further export bans
worth more than 11 billion euros
to deprive the Russian economy of
critical technology and industrial goods
for Maximum Impact
we're targeting many industrial goods
that Russia needs
and that it cannot get through
backfilling by Third countries
vital Goods such as Electronics
specialized Vehicles machine parts spare
parts for trucks and jet engines
and we are targeting Goods for the
construction sector which can be
directed to Russia's military such as
antennas or cranes
second we will further restrict the
export of dual used goods and advanced
Tech Goods
we propose controls on 47 electronic
components that can be used in Russian
weapon systems
including drones missiles and
helicopters
and on specific rare earth materials and
thermal cameras
with this we have banned All Tech
products found on the battlefield
and we will make sure that they don't
find other ways to get there
and this is why for the first time ever
we are adding Third Country entities to
the Russian dual use sanctions
Iran's revolutionary guards have been
providing Russia with Shahid drones to
attack civilian infrastructure in
Ukraine
therefore we are now adding seven
Iranian entities to our dual Jews regime
they are now under complete ban
to sell sensitive items to Russia
and we stand ready to list further
Iranian and other Third Country entities
that are providing sensitive technology
to Russia
this should act as a strong deterrent to
other companies and international
Traders
my third point is about Russia's
propaganda machine
poutine is also Waging War in the public
space
with an army of propagandists and
disinformation networks
they are spreading toxic lies to
polarize our societies so we are
proposing
to list Putin's propagandalists as well
as additional military and political
Commanders
High Representatives
will provide you with information on the
listings we are proposing today
we now have in place the toughest
sanctions ever introduced by the
European Union
and we have to ensure that they are
strictly applied
therefore our 10th package introduces
new measures to prevent circumvention
and this is my fourth point
we will track oligarchs trying to hide
or to sell their assets to escape
sanctions
and together with member states
we will set up an overview of all frozen
assets of the Russian Central Bank held
in the European Union
we need to know where these are located
and how much they are worth
this is crucial
in view of the possible use of public
Russian assets to fund reconstruction in
Ukraine
and finally we are working closely with
member states operators and partner
countries to tackle circumvention
our special Envoy David O'Sullivan is
reaching out to third countries to
ensure strict implementation of
sanctions and to prevent circumvention
and next week we will organize a
sanctions coordinator's forum
Gathering our International partners and
member states to strengthen enforcement
efforts
together we are tightening the screws on
Russia's more and more
I call on the member states to adopt
this new package of sanctions swiftly
our aim is to have together with our G7
partners
further significant sanctions in place
by February 24th
exactly one year after Putin launched
its Imperial War
we are approaching one year
since Russia's full-scale invasion of
Ukraine
until today Putin is escalating this
illegal aggression weaponizing winter
food and hunger
Russia continues to show its in human
phage with brutal missile Terror against
civilian targets
European Union has so far reacted with
unprecedented support to Ukraine
nine sanction packages
they are taking habitol on the Russian
economy and on the kremlin's ability to
finance its aggression
today as the president of the commission
has announced we are putting forward the
10th package of sanctions
against those who are instrumental in
the continuation of this brutal War
taking more measures tackling the
banking sector access to dual use
technology and targeting also Advanced
Technologies
additionally I am submitting to the
council a list of proposals to sanctions
for almost 100 additional individuals
and entities for their role in
undermining sovereignty and to return
Integrity of Ukraine
and this includes those responsible for
military activities for political
decisions propaganda and disinformation
we are targeting those involved in the
human
kidnappings deportation and forced
adoption of Ukrainian children to Russia
and also those enabling a Looting of
Ukrainian resources
we will again hit heart at the Russian
military and defense sector
to the organization related to them or
those responsible for the development of
drones that are targeting civilians and
civilian infrastructure
and they do not confined to Russia
today's proposal include a full
experiment on several Italian entities
involved in the manufacture and
provision of the unmanned aerial
Vehicles yesterday at the NATO meeting
we've got clear evidence that this is
happening
so we are proposed into sanction more
key decision makers senior government
officials and parliamentarians
I'm proposing to the member stage to
extend our sanctions to the proxy
authorities and the so-called judges
into four illegally and next Ukrainian
regions of the hands Dennis Kirsten and
separation who are providing fake
legitimacy to the Russian rulers and to
their illegal decisions
we are imposing restrictive measures on
media organizations on Persons and
organizations who are polluting the
public space with this information and
malicious narratives
adding to the military Warfare also
through information Warfare
we will continue to increase pressure in
Russia and we will do it for as long as
needed until Ukraine is liberated from
the brothel Russian accusation